hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar preservatives now
facts and fictions I'm Brenda Kelly kim
of lab roots and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab routes leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by lab
roots to learn more please visit www.fcn
let's get started you can post questions
to the speaker during your presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the Q&A box
which will open when you click the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience any technical problems seeing
or hearing this presentation just let us
know by clicking on the support button
found at the top right of the
presentation window or you can report
your problem by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left I'd like to
now present today's speaker dr. David
Steinberg with more than 30 years
industry experience David is a
world-renowned industry expert whose
preservative knowledge is second to none
he founded the master's program in
cosmetic Sciences at Fairleigh Dickinson
University and has taught many courses
including chemistry of skincare
chemistry of hair care ingredients
cosmetic raw material regulations and
preservatives for cosmetics in more than
15 years he loaded by monthly column for
cosmetics and toiletries magazine in
2006 he founded the cosmetic
preservative Council and served as
executive director he's a regulatory
affairs professional fellow and has
served as chapter chair national
treasurer and national president of the
Society of cosmetic chemists who is on
the board of directors for the
independent cosmetic manufacturers and
distributors Industry Association has
received many awards including eminent
visiting scholar Virginia State
University paper of the year
Australian society of cosmetic chemists
and society of cosmetic chemists merit
award is a featured speaker at many
industry events and always provides a
new perspective many find invaluable let
me turn you over to David now thank you
today we're going to be talking about
cosmetic and personal care preservatives
what is happening what I like to say is
facts and fiction you're going to hear a
lot more fiction than you are going to
be hearing facts because that's what's
happening to our world right now and i
would like to start off by answering the
question that i always get asked and
what is fraps no it's not something that
Starbucks got rid of crap stands for
fellow the regulatory affairs
professional society I am the first
person who was elevated to the status
who specializes in topical
pharmaceuticals and cosmetic regulations
so much for that where did our
preservative problems begin they started
and a different vein and the early 80s
when a distributor the very minor player
in UV filters went to it the one of the
small players and said we'd like to make
you an offer give us the exclusive
rights to sell your filter for ten years
at a healthy Commission rate and we're
going to make this the number one
selling UV filter in the world well they
got the agreement at that time the most
common filter was Panama dough which
goes by the inky name of ethylhexyl
dimethyl cava and although it doesn't
contain paba it's not made from paba
their biggest selling point for their UV
filter was the negative properties of
habit itself that habit itself is very
rarely used as a UV filter because it's
still water soluble it stains fabrics
and probably the most important thing is
it doesn't work unless you apply it at
least 30 minutes before you go out in
the Sun
which to me sort of some strange because
if you do that then every two hours you
have to go back inside for a get an hour
and reapply anyway guilt by association
led to the term have a free and suddenly
the free claims became a universal way
to market products now each time someone
comes up with a new free claim I get
calls from the press and the usually has
the same questions how many people did
you kill or injure before you remove
this horrible chemical from your product
the answer is always none that doesn't
stop them they then say what other toxic
chemicals are in your product that you
haven't removed yet and then the last
question which is the deadly question
for our industry shouldn't the FDA
pre-approved all cosmetics and all
ingredients that go into cosmetics
because clearly self-regulation is not
working so what do we find go to the
shelf of any store and you're going to
see have a free trip listen free
formaldehyde-free glycol free
preservative free alcohol free
everything's pretty except the price now
advertising standards of canada that's
part of the government of canada
considers free claims to be inherently
false and misleading so let me give you
some of the comments and how they deal
with it and we're going to use as the
example hydrogen cyanide free good good
chemical latihan or products and they've
issued conditions which must be met to
make such a claim the first thing is you
must have used this ingredient in your
product and that it was sold in canada
and that it was properly registered and
the dates it was started to be sold in
canada you make the decision you're
going to remove it so you must notify
the government that you have removed
this ingredient from your product you
also must show outside analysis that
there is none detectable amounts of this
ingredient in your product and if you
meet these conditions you're allowed to
make this free of claim
for one year but at the end of one year
any product with this free of claim must
be removed from the shelf no cell
through which has led to the retail
outlets saying when your people come in
to market your product and it says
hydrogen cyanide free they don't want it
on your shelf because they will be
responsible for getting it off the shelf
in one year and returning it to you and
that's not what they want to do now when
Canada came up with this standard it
applied to everything and there are some
very important questions raised about
what can we say because it's important
to warn consumers about things so they
allow claims like this product was never
formulated with hydrogen cyanide this
product naturally contains no hydrogen
cyanide we do not have hydrogen cyanide
in this product now all these claims
must be true and you must prove them if
you're going to make these comments it
wasn't hydrogen cyanide that caused the
question the question really was from
the food industry about sugar for people
who are diabetics who needed to know
whether there was sugar in the product
well marketers are quick to follow
through on saying free of anything that
will sell one more bottle and frankly
don't care about the consequences of
importance to the people who export
England and France have prohibited free
claims for personal care products and
they have requested a formal court to
make this part of the European
regulations I believe it will pass
within the next two years now when you
go to formulate those your marketing
department restrict you I do a lot of
ingredient reviews for many different
cosmetic companies and each one seems to
have a list of prohibited chemicals
which we just call the no notice and
some of the most common or parabens
products that contain chlorine or iodine
products that are poor made from
ethylene oxide from
aldehyde the ISO thiazole owns glycols
alcohols acids that's just about covers
all or preservatives I don't think
there's anything that they like so why
do they do this it's because the NGOs
the non-governmental organizations have
been attacking chemicals for years and
they have found a lot of focus and
attention on preservatives you need to
understand that their goal is not safety
but it's money they do this by trying to
scare people and they do this because
they have two great friends who help
them do this the first is the media
whether it be television or the internet
or radio or newspapers or magazines the
media is quick to publish whatever the
NGO say without checking the facts
whether it's true or even more important
whether it's really relevant and this is
followed by the marketers accounts
cosmetics who as soon as they hear o
parabens are bad we're going to take all
the carbons out of our products and
become paraben free when this first
happened I was asked by one company what
to replace the parents with and I said
let's be very realistic about this how
many products do you have with parabens
and he said over a thousand I said and
how long will it take you to take the
Paragons out put something else in test
for see whether they work do the safety
over again do the stability over again
do the claim substantiation over again
repackage and real able your products
and he said an awful lot of money and I
said and where's your budget for this so
I said why don't you go back to
marketing and say this is what it's
going to cost could you please give me a
budget for this so I can hire enough
people so we can do this because it will
take me working in my lab right now is
it we have and what they I'll be able to
about six products a year
can we have over a thousand to do he
says they'll fire me if I say that to
them and I said good i'll be an expert
witness for you for a false discriminate
false firing lawsuit because he told him
the truth so he sent it to them and he
called me up a minute later they said
don't use parabens in any new products
don't reformulate so that's what happens
to us who is the environmental working
group that just look at their mission
statement the mission of the
Environmental Working Group is to use
the power of public information to
protect public health and the
environment that sounds nice go to their
website and the first thing you see is
they want money contribute now forget
about everything else we just want your
money the first preservative that was
really successfully attacked was
parabens and this has been followed by
triclosan and quaternion 15 the ISO
fazza loans from aldehyde releasers
acids glycols phenoxyethanol and just
about everything else we use so let's
look at the facts and the fiction about
parabens the first paper attacking
parabens was a Japanese paper published
in 2005 that said feeding huge amounts
of parabens to rats resulted in around a
ten percent reduction of the rat sperm
count I guess if it was higher than that
we could sell it as a road inside did
this mean anything no because we don't
eat cosmetics so ingestion of parabens
is not a really interesting topic it
went nowhere it was followed shortly
thereafter by a very broad European
paper talking about endocrine disruptors
and they came out with certain
structures and they said these
structures have the possibility of maybe
being endocrine disruptors the FDA
looked at this progress paper and did
some testing and published and you can
find it on their website that the
paraben that has the highest endocrine
disruption potential is butyl paraben
and that is one 100,000 as potent and
endocrine disruptor as estradiol which
is a true endocrine disruptor so all
this nonsense about endocrine disruptors
is just that it's fiction then came the
paper in early spring of 2006 bye Darby
from England who found breast cancer
tissues and found parabens in them she
attributed this to the use of parabens
in underarm antiperspirant that was
rather strange we've never put parabens
and underarm antiperspirant also how do
parabens get from the underarm to the
breast to cause breast cancer actually
there were two important questions that
the author never wanted to discuss the
first was were the patients that she
tested one chemotherapy I find this to
be a very critical question because a
lot of the chemotherapy drugs are
preserved with parabens and the second
thing is if they were on chemotherapy
one of the major side effects of the
chemotherapy besides loss of hair is
while you're getting the stuff poured
into your veins you feel terribly
nauseous and the answer is liquid and
acids and all liquidy announces are
preserved with parabens well about a
month later the author changed her mind
but by then it was too late in a six one
six week period it was all over the news
the parabens caused breast cancer which
is just nonsense first her controls had
higher carbon levels than the tumors
that she found in the subjects the
second thing was how many subjects did
she tests the number was eight that's
not significant that's just ridiculous
so but it caught on so what has happened
we're probably going to lose the c3 the
propo
the butyl parabens they're the least
effective so I'm not going to lose too
much sleep about it already the European
Union has said that you cannot use the
c3 or c4 higher than a total point 19
individual your combined the ISO
parabens isopropyl paraben isobutyl
paraben and benzyl parabens are no
longer permitted in the European Union
okay the truth is we've been using
parabens for over 80 years and cosmetics
some foods drugs and it's really safe
there's no real science that says
parabens or anything but say in fact
they are probably the safest
preservatives we can use they certainly
are the most safety tested the European
ban on the iso parabens was not because
they were unsafe it was because they
weren't supported they requested
scientific tests which would cost more
than the annual sales total in the world
of the iso parabens so the manufacturers
in the ice apart and just said we're not
going to spend that kind of money that's
ridiculous we'll never get our money
back on this so it is now on there annex
to prohibited list there are a lot of
things that are on the prohibited list
that are really not unsafe they're just
not supported I think they should change
their list too what is unsafe and what
is not supporting in the United States
the cosmetic ingredient review reviewed
this again and again and again they
disagreed with the European scientific
committees findings and they continue to
say that the parabens and the ISO
parabens are safe as they are currently
used we're about trickle saying everyone
hates triclosan now the most common
thing I hear is that it's a pesticide
well yes it is because triclosan has
many industrial applications industrial
applications require approval by the
Environmental Protection Agency under
fifra and the end result is that EPA
classifies as
different anything that is a
preservative is a pesticide so yes it's
true but is it meaningful and the answer
is no they say that it contains
chloroform there's never been any fine
they say it contains dioxin now dioxins
a real bad actor dioxin is the major
ingredient that was an agent orange
however triclosan has extremely tight
USB specifications and you met amounts
of dioxin that are allowed are in the
parts per billion range they claim it's
an endocrine disruptor there's no
evidence that this has happened you
constantly hear that it causes
antibiotic resistance the first paper is
what they usually site and no one's ever
been able to duplicate the work of the
first paper there is no technical kata
proof that triclosan causes antibiotic
resistance it's just another one of
these science fiction's that we hear all
the time the real facts is our that we
don't use trick with seen as a
preservative it has a very narrow
activity range and that's against some
grand positive bacteria it does find use
in cosmetics in underarm deodorants not
antiperspirant and the only people who
use underarm deodorants are men so the
volume of trip us and for the cosmetic
use is extremely low however it's big
uses in drugs especially in our industry
and over-the-counter soaps and cleansers
and body washes which all fall under the
category of antimicrobial body washes
the FDA approximately it's almost two
years now went into a consent decree
from a lawsuit in which they have set up
a timetable and it is very possible
within the next year to two years you
will see that antimicrobial soaps liquid
cleansers and body washes
longer be allowed as OTC drugs in the
united states that you will not be able
to make the claims probably a year after
that you will see the same for the Levon
products which are usually emulsions
that contain a quaternion compound then
a year to that they will come up with
what they're going to do with the
alcohol-based hand sanitizers and that
will probably remain although I suspect
they might limit its use for
professional use and restaurants in
washrooms and public areas things like
that but not for home use it's not that
useful it kills the bugs on your skin
real quickly but after it evaporates
about five minutes later they're right
back there so the long term effects are
very new big latest one to meet the
wrath of the NGOs was quaternion 15 this
preservative was the original
preservative used in Johnson Johnson's
baby shampoo and similar baby shampoo
products generic ones and other
producers it also found use in
preserving mascara it was very active
against gram-negative bacteria the
campaign for safe cosmetics which
happens to have the exact same officers
as the environmental working group
started attacking johnson johnson in
2009 and finally launched the video
called the toxic tub on the internet the
mainstream media picked this up
immediately and the toxic tub basically
said that baby shampoo contained
quaternion 15 which causes cancer nitro
it contains 14 dioxin which causes
cancer not true they just kept on
attacking it for various things okay so
what happened is the J&J capitulated
this resulted in a new I guess word in
our vocabulary because the NGOs have
threatened other major cosmetic
companies who don't
do what they would like them to do and
they have threatened them with things
like we will toxic tub you we will come
out with the same thing but we will
attack you instead of J&J one company
who was faced with this issue promptly
sent them a letter from their lawyer
saying you do this and you will be in
court for the rest of your life the
facts are JJ has significant safety data
on baby shampoo going back from when
they first started working on it but the
marketing pressure which included a
significant amount of spam
letter-writing just was too much and the
marketers of baby shampoos surrendered
so they took the quaternion 15 out and
they took out all the other ingredients
that they disliked and reformulated with
this loss of the major business the
manufacturer for turning 15 decided not
to support its use in any more cosmetic
applications it is used under a
different name for industrial purposes
and as a result the EU provoked proposed
this year to remove it from there annex
five positive list of preservatives and
the manufacturer said we're not going to
support it for cosmetics anymore so this
is destined to hit the annex to prohibit
prohibited greeting list so if you're
using for turning 15 and you're
exporting to Europe you'll need to
reformulate the other thing is that once
this becomes official in Europe there
are many other markets that follow the
European Union regulations which include
Latin and South America the Middle East
the AZ impact countries new zealand
turkey Russia the ones it's easier to
name the countries that don't follow it
which is the United States Canada and
Australia Japan Korea and that's about
it that leads us to formaldehyde
formaldehyde refers to the anhydrous gas
it mixes with water and it gets
converted to a compound called methylene
glycol the market
chemical society recognizes these as two
different chemicals with different cas
numbers the methylene glycol is so
common it's in every cell of our body in
small amounts and whenever you exhale
you are releasing some of this into the
atmosphere when we used formaldehyde
which was back up until the 60s or early
70s in cosmetics as a preservative
typical concentrations attempt the two
tenths of a percent the big objection
was it was a sensitizer yes when left on
the skin it does cause low levels of
sensitization when used in shampoos and
conditioners wash all products this is
not the case because of this products
that release very low levels of
formaldehyde were discovered and
marketed they're much safer they don't
give you the sensitization and they give
us the best protection against
gram-negative bacteria in all types of
formulations very important issue what
we deal with in governments in the late
70s early 80s the first introduction of
the mixed iso files loans came to the
cosmetic industry this was a 3 to 1
mixture plus salsa stabilizers of the
methylchloroisothiazolinone and the
starting material the methyl iso file
alone and these are abbreviated mci in
mi the combination was sold with the
recommendation the maximum used level
was 15 parts per million of the active
ingredients and recommended for wash off
applications only in Europe they used it
in levon applications at levels like 30
to 90 parts per million and promptly
sensitized a tremendous amount of the
population they stopped doing that and
the issues really disappeared the
methylisothiazolinone is offered alone
about 10 years ago and it was suggested
for Levon applications along with wash
off
because the methylchloroisothiazolinone
was the major sensitizer based on all
the data it was approved in Europe and
was one of the first new preservatives
approved in Japan after Japan changed
their cosmetic regulations maximum level
100 parts per million most people used
it at 95 parts per million why it was
sold as a nine point five percent
solution in water yeah add a tenth of a
percent you're putting in 95 parts per
million network in 2014 it was named the
contact dermatitis sensitizer of the
year this got a lot of press it's
strange the press never said anything
when cocamidopropyl betaine was named
the contact dermatitis sensitizer the
year you can see where their issues lie
preservatives are great whipping voice
because of all the issues that have come
about two things have happened the
European Union has reduced the maximum
level from a hundred to 15 parts per
million and for wash off only the facts
are the cosmetic ingredient review was
very much aware of what was happening
with this and they also looked and said
you know if we ban this because it's
such a sensitizer we don't have too many
preservatives that marketing is allowing
any more so this year they concluded
that the methylisothiazolinone on
sensitizing it's very possible that the
methyl isocyanate depending on what you
have in their type of formulations
inhibitors things like this in the 25 to
50 parts per million range and as a
result you might find that you can use
it and not be a sensitizer however the
damage has been done in the manufacturer
says they're not going to recommend this
relieved on products
anymore if you can't stand the heat get
out of the kitchen okay one of our other
preserved as they're being attacked now
we use glycols the c5 c6 c8 some c10 and
these are 12 dials this is where you'll
find the capital glycol we'll talk more
about that later there is some
sensitization it's nothing to worry
about it's in about the same level we
have sensitization to things like the
parabens which are some of the least
sensitizing things on the marketplace
things like that however the NGOs are
attacking them as being toxic chemicals
why well ethylene glycol which just has
the honor of going on proposition 65 for
a reproductive toxicity by ingestion
it's sinking aim is black hole okay so
as well you know these are all flight
bowls if definitely glycol will kill you
so will these I guess what the press
listens to them no one ever challenges
these types of stupid remarks the press
doesn't try to see if they're true or
not they just go right ahead and attack
them the interesting fact about these
are none of these are approved as
preservatives in any country that has a
positive list to preserve this the
United States and Canada does not have a
positive list that we just go ahead and
sell them if you ask the sellers of
these products they say well they're
moisturizers and there's something else
and by the way they make your emulsions
anti-bacterial strange ok Benz awaits
this is one of the interesting ones it
goes back about 10 to 12 years ago and
it was linked to a reaction of sodium
benzoate with a score of the casa de
benzoic acid with ascorbic acid to form
benzene and this didn't happen in
cosmetics this happened in a very
popular water beverage known as Perrier
and I taught organic chemistry over 50
year
ago I have never figured out how you can
react an acid a cyclic acid like benzoic
acid with the complex acid like a score
big acid in form a hydrocarbon it can
form it by reducing them but they don't
react to form a reducing agent so I
never understood this as two Perrier
they finally found the source of the
benzene was not from the Perrier who is
coming from lubricant that was being
used and the chain belts on the assembly
line to bottle the hurry a hoarder no
one remembers that anymore one of the
other kind whipping boys that we have to
deal with it is our favorite
preservative right now and that's
phenoxyethanol phenoxyethanol has always
been hated by the French because it is a
one mole of box lid now one mole of
ethylene oxide on methanol or ethanol or
those very short chain alcohols form
solvents that are never used in cosmetic
industry who are extremely carcinogenic
and toxic and they're not nice things so
that's why we don't use them in
cosmetics they don't have any utility
the paint industry uses them I don't
care about the paint industry we don't
use them in nail polishes don't worry
about that but this leads us to what is
this meanwhile the French said if one
more boxes of short-chain helpfuls our
bit for all one mole with oxygen a they
have proposed to the European Union to
restrict its live news from one percent
2.4% for children's products three years
and younger prohibited in the nappy
areas they like the court most of their
issues are due to data from my tea after
World War two when we used a very crude
form of phenoxyethanol for paint
stripping and it had lots of authority
and purity such as phenol and dioxane
and all sorts of diet monomers and
dimers and trimers it's a complex
reaction it sounds simple to
put phenyl in one mole of ethylene oxide
and will allow you get phenoxyethanol so
let's go to one of the things that is
close one of the major problems and that
is Minnesota now Minnesota is one of my
favorite states many years ago they
passed the law prohibiting the use of
mercury to preserve cosmetics sold in
the state of Minnesota I found out who
was the author of the bill and I wrote
him an email along with the largest
newspaper congratulated him for making
the citizens of Minnesota so much safer
and then I said of course you realize
that we have not used mercury to
preserve cosmetics since the early 70s
and that even if you wanted to use
mercury to preserve cosmetics there's no
manufacturer of this anymore so what's
your next move to make the citizens safe
prohibit Martians from driving on the
right hand side of the road one months
that begin with Z sincerely David
Steinberg about two seconds later the
newspaper called me back and said you're
being facetious I said no you're wrong
why didn't you even challenge this guy
that there is no use of mercury why is
he introducing a bill well it was
populism so what do they do next they
passed a bill in twenty and twenty
thirteen and this is a strange bill what
you do is they prohibit formaldehyde or
formaldehyde releasers from any
children's products not just cosmetics
any children's products as of August of
2014 now this is interesting because one
of the major uses of formaldehyde isn't
permanent press fabric and you'll be
able to find from out behind you know
parts per million one to two to 10 parts
per million in any permanent press
fabric I guess they're banned in
Minnesota now for children they'd find
children as eight years of age younger
and in cosmetics you cannot replace this
with any chemical known or suspected
development toxicity causes cancer
genetic damage reproductive harm
disrupts the endocrine or hormone system
damages the nervous system immune system
or causes systemic toxicity what other
crimes can be suspected of the
disappearance of Jimmy Hoffa I don't
know this is just the shopping list of
any type of thing no proof is necessary
where we have to do is say suspected and
you can't use it well that lift left us
with real major problems we couldn't or
we didn't have answers for two different
specific problems we had answers for
hatching hydrous products they really
don't need preservatives emulsions we
could use the caprylic like oh and
probably be very safe in that respect
but what happens when we use surfactant
based products such as shampoos body
washes and wipes we suddenly found that
nothing would work there because
gram-negative bacteria would just grow
like crazy also what about the traces of
formaldehyde refined in the fatty
alcohols which are the base for all the
surfactants what about that well here
are the formaldehyde releasing
preservatives that they hate there was
Emma days love the new urien die is Ola
Linda new uri at the md midn 2013 15
sodium hydroxymethyl isolate and then I
listed the three which you rarely used
the enemy the 5 405 nitro 13 dioxane and
the to bromo to nitro propane 13 dial we
just don't use them very much well they
discovered that products were
disappearing from the marketplace so a
year later they revised the law and this
is really bizarre that the chemical is
intentionally added ingredient that
degrades under normal conditions of
temperature and pressure we have
cosmetics under pressure except for
aerosols which don't need preservatives
don't understand that to release free
formaldehyde it is prohibited at the
level of free formaldehyde is above zero
point 05
said so we can use the formaldehyde
releasers as long as we test for and I
can show you methods to show that they
don't release from a light above zero
point oh five percent because they
didn't state any method for this the law
also bans triclosan for all products not
approved by the FDA which means the men
in Minnesota I guess are not going to be
able to use the utterance anymore
they're gonna have to switch to
antiperspirant well I said we had
trouble adequately preserving products
while people tried and we've already had
recalls of baby wipes and shampoo
because of this contamination marketers
have just said we're not going to sell
in Minnesota anymore and who suffers the
consumers congratulations okay the
latest disaster which most of you are
aware of are the organic or natural
markets who subscribe to the theory that
all preservatives are bad the only ones
they permit are very weak and usually
very ineffective and there are some that
cannot be made from petrochemicals if
you want to meet the definition of the
USDA for being organic certified they
have preservatives that are allowed but
they cannot be made from petrochemicals
there's only one problem that's what
they're made from there are no natural
sources of these so what do we find when
we look at these organic products we
start to find massive contaminations
usually coming from poor gmps but
especially coming from spores from the
raw materials and what would you expect
when they're grown with natural
fertilizers you can figure that one out
for yourself so what are we really using
now let's forget all the issues we have
let's find out what we really are
preserving our products with and I write
the frequency of use every four years in
that general time period to find out
what they actually are they're developed
from the FDA's voluntary reporting list
but I also get the list from Canada
because Canada has mandatory
registration of the cosmetics so their
numbers are truly indicative of what the
real facts are so let's look at the most
commonly used preservatives now the
number of formulations that these are
based on 4 2015 it's about 150,000
products so you can see phenoxy and in
2010 it was around 85,000 products so if
you do the math you can see
phenoxyethanol is the number one used
preservative caprylic like holes the
number two it is frequently used
together the mci mi combination is very
popular for shampoos and rinse all
products the first paraben on the list
is propylparaben and then you find the
soft preservatives sorbic acid benzoic
acid benzyl alcohol is your quote
natural but they're actually synthetic
this reflects the natural markets then
we come down to methyl paraben and look
at the drop-in methylparaben use from
twenty ten to twenty fifteen the hydro
acetic acid has grown and other week
preservatives and for Tennyson continues
to show some growth I just got to notice
I'm trying to read okay I don't know
where it is so I'm not going to do it
here are the rest of them butylparaben
methylisothiazolinone in five years has
dropped in hand the formaldehyde
releasers have dropped the ILO propanol
butyl carbonate is down to some degree
the isopropyl isobutyl paraben is down
isobutyl parents big use was in a
mixture with methyl ethyl propyl
butylparaben dissolved in phenoxyethanol
you're probably familiar with this
combination triclosan has dropped what
turned 15 is almost off the map so where
is this leading us it is leading us that
paraben-free claims is caught
significant drop the formaldehyde
preservatives that release from ala hi
are disappearing an oxy ethanol
entrepreneur glycol when used with an
antifungal agent these products are not
antifungal are now the most common used
in emulsions we're still going to use
the method for iso thadland
methylisothiazolinone for rinse off
products and the soft preserve the
sorbic benzoic the hydro acetic acid are
finding increased usage and I think I
have done this just at the right time so
I'll be glad to take any of your
questions there's a place somewhere
where you click for questions and
answers and we'll see how many we can
get through with that while we're have
the time we do have a stop at ten
o'clock any ones which I have not
answered you have my email address here
be glad to answer if you send me the
email so with that I guess we now go to
questions and answers thank you David
very much for that presentation I'm just
going to give our audience a few minutes
and a reminder of how to submit their
questions questions can be submitted by
typing them any green Q&A box which is
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and hopefully we're
going to get those questions streaming
in and daivyn can answer them let's see
our first question for David from jeff
at abbott laboratories what do we use
that is not on some list somewhere the
answer to the question is excuse me the
answer the question is something that
marketing is not going to want to hear
and that is unit doses and aseptic
packaging that you manufacture
your product to be used once and you
manufacture its sterile that way you
will never have to use a preservative
there isn't a preservative that isn't
under attack some sort of way shape or
form okay interesting answer our next
question from the gym at Dow Corning
corporation is the nappy area
restriction specific to patient age or
just general population the nappy area
is strictly for children 3 years of age
and younger is what is being proposed
for the European Union okay great thank
you for those answers I'm just looking
at our Q&A column to see what we have
next we'll make sure our audience has
time is a lot of information there and
our next question from Angelica at ipn
Mexico what do you think about potential
microbial products as substitutes of
chemical preservatives ah that's an
interesting question that's an
interesting question this has been
something that's been published and
started the grain grow some interest
that let's put some sort of good
bacteria that killed the bad bacteria I
have some problems with this I'm not
sure it's going to give us the real
long-term needs that we have we have
some real interesting situations which
no one really likes to talk about but I
have spoken about this because I think
we all need to face the facts officially
we add preservatives to clean products
to prevent contamination under normal
and foreseeable consumer use
and this has been the gospel I heard
this when I took my first course in
cosmetic chemistry in 1969 I have heard
it as recently as last month's edition
of the British society of cosmetic
chemist Journal it's just not true we've
got to face the facts the facts are we
put preservatives into our product to
prevent contaminations during
manufacturing yes we need to preserve
them for consumer use but I have never
found an issue or a case in which
regulatory action was taken because the
consumer contaminated a product if you
look at all the recalls and there are a
lot of them including the natural
products and things like this it is
because the products were contaminated
when they left the plan not before the
consumers got their dirty hands and
fingers in them now there are certain
things which we do know and that is if
you have wide mouth jars the consumer
sticks their fingers in that's more of a
problem than putting it in a tube with a
narrow orifice and one type of
contamination the consumers really see
that they cause is mold they stick their
fingers in and the next day they open
the joy they see black fuzzy stuff just
like we do on the bread but our major
use of preservatives are during
manufacturing so there are several
things you can do if you're going to use
the week or preservatives be sure you
really tighten up your gmps use hasit
find out where contamination is taking
place it increases your manufacturing
costs but if you can't use preservatives
and can use active and strong
preservatives this is what you can do
thank you David our next question
Holmgren and I open outcomes can you
recommend references for methods and
costs for testing ingredients and
formulated products getting on the
positive lists yes if you would like I
can if you drop me an email I can give
you a link and if I don't have the link
i will just copy it of the requirements
for submission to get on the positive
list of the European Union it has been
published and I have the link and I will
be glad to send it over to you thank you
for that information David I don't see
any more questions in our QA q I'm just
going to give our audience another
second to do that it's sometimes a bit
of slow coming in but um expense of
great information that you've had here
today David and I think everybody's
probably learned a lot about you know
what's really going on with
preservatives and what we put in the
products we use so i think we're going
to wrap it up there I don't see any more
questions but I just see that david's
email is available we'd like to thank
david steinberg again for joining us
today and our attendings for all their
interesting questions as I said you have
his contact information if there's
something we didn't get to today I'm
sure we can follow up with you I want to
let our audience know that the webcast
can be viewed on demand through the
februari of 2016 and lab which is the
molar all of you via email when it's
available for replay and we would
encourage you to share this email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time I'd
like to thank David again till his time
David do you have any final comments for
us yeah keep the faith we'll get through
this
great I see actually if you have a
moment David we had one more question
from Brent and she tells us about
anthropogenic chemicals are altering the
microbial world a session that's been in
this event and has some useful
information so if you'd like to look at
that that will also be available for
replay on lab routes thank you again
David for your time thank our audience
and that's all we have for today until
next time thank you you too bye